ah
la temporada de carnaval se desarrolla
en alemania a pesar del cobijo
las festividades comenzaron en la ciudad
de colonia y allí las personas se
divierten casi como antes de la pandemia
es bueno que podamos festejar durante la
época del coronavirus aquí es muy seguro
los controles son estrictos es genial
nos sentimos muy seguros aquí
quienes consideran inseguro estar cerca
de cientos de personas sin máscaras
evitaron la multitud
alemania ha superado los 50 mil nuevos
contagios diarios la cifra más alta
hasta ahora muchos alemanes están
vacunados alrededor del 78 por ciento de
las personas mayores de 12 años ha
recibido al menos una dosis pero en el
este del país algunos estados se han
quedado rezagados el actual
vicecanciller alemán y aspirante a
canciller olaf scholz aseguró que ha
llegado el momento de adoptar nuevas
medidas para todo el país
[Aplausos]
queremos la regla 3g en el lugar de
trabajo hay que vacunarse recuperarse o
hacerse una prueba para poder trabajar
island y cáceres a hacer campaña por la
vacuna alentar la aplicación de una
tercera dosis presionar para que las
personas se hagan la prueba y buscar que
el proceso vuelva a ser gratuito son
algunos de los incentivos mientras tanto
a las personas no vacunadas se les
podría prohibir el acceso a determinados
lugares medidas que el parlamento está
preparado para examinar y votar
adicionalmente la próxima semana el
gobierno federal prevé reunirse con los
líderes de los 16 estados de alemania